llegó el momento de la información
económica por ello me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañero jorge hurtado jorge
bienvenido en esta crónica vamos a
hablar de las sanciones impuestas a
varios multimillonarios rusos acusados
de tener estrechos vínculos con el
gobierno ruso así valentín nadie que tan
solo esta semana el reino unido- impuso
sanciones económicas y financieras a
siete oligarcas rusos según el primer
ministro del reino unido- boris johnson
la sanción busca que no existe refugio
seguro para quienes apoyan la invasión
en ucrania entre los sancionados se
encuentra roman abramovich dueño del
club de fútbol chelsea acusado de tener
una estrecha relación con el gobierno
ruso durante décadas al igual que otros
oligarcas entre las sanciones destaca la
congelación de todos sus activos en
reino unido- que tienen un valor neto
colectivo de alrededor de 20 mil
millones de dólares y la prohibición
también de viajará a esa zona pero
quienes quienes son estos oligarcas y
cómo llegaron a europa se lo preguntamos
a josé luis orella él es profesor de
historia contemporánea y nos comenta
esto desde españa
la primera generación la generación más
antigua
desde luego buscando una mayor libertad
de movimientos al pertenecer a los
círculos de oposición de vladimir putin
la segunda generación de oligarcas desde
luego por razones puramente
empresariales ellos guardan muy buena
relación con el cual el poder no
obstante ellos les interesa estar en
europa principalmente la ciudad de
londres porque es el gran epicentro de
los intercambios del comercio
internacional y por tanto ellos están en
su ámbito de trabajo y de relación a los
oligarcas más importantes son
representativos de empresas exportadoras
de gas natural de petróleo y de
minerales raros entonces tienen podemos
decir ese ambiente y luego habría
también su sector que estarían en países
mediterráneos costa mediterránea
española o italiana para invertir la
parte de los beneficios sobre todo en la
industria turística donde a algunos les
gusta pues residir lógicamente por no
por nuestra climatología bueno pues ya
16 días de invasión y la guerra empieza
a tener consecuencias en las finanzas de
estos oligarcas así es de hecho al 3 de
marzo el patrimonio neto de los
oligarcas rusos había perdido en
conjunto unos 88 mil millones de dólares
en comparación con el 23 de febrero un
día antes de la invasión según el índice
de multimillonarios de bloomberg el
presidente de lukoil vaguit alekpérov
fue el mayor perdedor su riqueza
personal cayó más del 60 por ciento
antes de salir de la lista de bloomberg
el 2 de marzo también vladimir potanin
el hombre más rico de rusia vio como las
acciones de su empresa que también
cotiza en londres que hay en más del 50
por ciento lo que supuso una pérdida de
4500 millones de dólares de su fortuna
personal entre el 23 de febrero y el 3
de marzo mientras que roman abramovich
perdió alrededor de 2 mil millones de
dólares sobre los por ciento de su
fortuna desde el 23 de febrero los
oligarcas rusos también vieron como las
autoridades han comenzado a decomisar
buena parte de sus propiedades entre
ellos yates de lujo las autoridades se
incautaron un yate de 213 pies propiedad
de alexei mordashóv en italia mientras
que en el puerto francés de la ciudad
fue incautado el yate de 280 pies de
igor sechín así como un complejo
turístico de 18 millones de dólares de
alisher usmánov pero como sería el
escenario para los oligarcas rusos y
para la economía de rusia como tal luego
de que pase esta guerra se lo
preguntamos al profesor luis orella y
esto nos dijo inicialmente un poco
difícil porque desde luego después de
después de una guerra y la vinculación
económica de rusia cada vez está yendo
de más hacia asia no o sea no solo con
china que nos fijamos todos sino que por
ejemplo estos días acababa de firmar y
aún con un contrato bastante amplio con
la propia pakistán o para abastecimiento
sobre gas natural entonces el recobrar
desde luego el mercado europeo y las
relaciones por ganarte a ser también
bueno por las dos partes la necesidad
que tenga también europa de volver otra
vez a tener una dependencia energética
con rusia pero como ya muy cuidada y muy
vinculada a otro tipo también de accesos
como puede ser eeuu que es uno de los
grandes ganadores económicos de esta
guerra y también de suministradores
procedentes de el norte de áfrica como
puede ser a argelia o incluso la lejana
qatar no entonces en ese aspecto pues se
van a tener que llegar a acuerdos
yo creo que llegarán desde luego acuerdo
pero inicialmente costará bastante no
jorge pues muchas gracias por esta
ampliación económica ustedes por su
sintonía continúen con nosotros que hay
más en france 24
[Música]